three years ago so my best friend is
somehow is his relative and we met there
but six months ago we bumped into each
other we've been texting a lot he
started talking to me about the marriage
and all stuff her parents they met
already and then he gave me a surprise
and proposed me so yeah it was a very
quick thing and in six months I'm here
and prepping up with my wedding things
you guys never dated right never Indian
mythology and how it works in India is
like it's not about the girl it's not
about the boy when we talk about
marriage here it's been taken as a very
sacred stuff where it's not about that
you can just date somebody
undateable you can just follow her or
not so our parents started this thing
where they actually started vouching for
what both of our family does who they
are from where they have come from do we
have a common culture do we have common
values are we from the same same
cultural background so that we can
really dwell with each other a lot of
Americans might ask is this love how do
you reply say that I think for me it's
arranged come love marriage the kids in
the six months we both have realized a
lot of things and touch word things fell
into such a great place that now I can
just say you know that I love him a lot
too in India is all about companionship
it's all how much you give respect to
each other it's all about how you treat
their parents it's all about how well
you think about each other and what your
future plans are love in India it's very
deep it's not just how you are in the
society it's how you are from inside and
that's how my parents have lived how
parents have lived and how much did your
families play a role in directing you
both together we guys are the engines
but the petrol and diesel they were the
one that you